y llegó el momento de hablar te saludo
en directo a América le doy la
bienvenida entonces a mi compañera mar
Romero salamar muy buenos días Buenos
días Andrés mar hoy vamos a hablar de un
tema que da bastante o que hemos
desarrollado bastante a lo largo de
nuestras jornadas y es la Inteligencia
artificial hoy vamos a centrarnos en su
aplicación en el campo de la salud cómo
es esto sí pues innegablemente es el
tema del momento y de hecho las mismas
organizaciones de salud como la OMS
lanzaron ayer un comunicado advirtiendo
de los riesgos que puede conllevar usar
la Inteligencia artificial en temas tan
delicados a veces como la salud pero
también sabemos que puede ser una
herramienta muy poderosa si se usa
correctamente como la mayoría para
hablar de esto nos acompaña Oscar Franco
que es el director del departamento de
salud pública de la Universidad de
utreck mucho Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos doctor Franco queríamos
preguntarlo preguntarle primero por la
Inteligencia artificial como algo que
hablamos del futuro no algo que parece
que va a venir pero en verdad hay
aplicaciones ya que se estén dando hoy
en día en el campo de la salud que
conozcamos
Sí buenos días Mary y no es algo del
futuro es algo del pasado de hecho
llevamos años utilizando lo utilizamos
en el pasado por ejemplo para
identificar Cómo arrugas o
manifestaciones en la cara de las
personas podrían determinar la edad de
las personas que ha llevado la
tecnología del desarrollo de del
reconocimiento facial Hace cuatro años
establecíamos el centro de Inteligencia
artificial en medicina en Berna y ahora
mismo nutre por ejemplo dirijo el
laboratorio de de Inteligencia
artificial para para vivir
saludablemente y lo que buscamos es eso
es utilizar la tecnología para mejorar
el cuidado de los pacientes de las
personas en general antes de que sean
pacientes y ayudar a mejorar la salud a
beber de una manera más saludable y
evitar las enfermedades doctor Franco ya
se ha empezado a hablar de o se ha
empezado a aplicar la Inteligencia
artificial en varios procesos médicos
esta tecnología podría reducir los
errores humanos o médicos en la atención
a pacientes
sí tiene un potencial enorme porque como
seres humanos tenemos ciertas
limitaciones
esta tecnología están en permanente
aprendizaje recoge información de una
manera muy rápida que nosotros como
seres humanos no podemos hacerlo y nos
ayuda a mejorar la identificación de
enfermedades la identificación de
patrones que pueden llevar a riesgos y
pueden también ayudar a complementar el
conocimiento médico para reducir esos
errores que pueden ocurrir en el momento
del diagnóstico Incluso el tratamiento y
también de la predicción cuando Queremos
saber que hay personas pueden
desarrollar ciertas enfermedades o
ciertas patologías al futuro
doctor sin embargo detrás de la
Inteligencia artificial hay humanos
también no somos los humanos que hemos
creado esta tecnología y por lo tanto
existe Entonces el riesgo de que herede
también algunos de los sesgos raciales o
de género que muchas veces también se le
critican a la medicina a la hora de
hacer sus diagnósticos y sus
explicaciones
porque ha sido generada Generalmente por
países ricos utilizando información que
se utiliza para aprendizaje para
aprendizaje ese aprendizaje automático
que básicamente se basa en información
de personas que viven en estos países
ricos que la mayoría de los casos son
personas blancas son hombres también
entonces cuando se aplican a mujeres o
personas con otro tipo de
pueden tener sesgos y pueden llevar un
diagnóstico inadecuado o pueden llevar a
una determinación que no es la más
adecuada para ese paciente precisamente
doctor desde su perspectiva como médico
qué le da más miedo y qué le entusiasma
sobre el uso de la Inteligencia
artificial en la salud
hay varias cosas que dan miedo no sé si
han visto la película Terminator es algo
que me acuerdo haberlo visto en mi niñez
Y que ahora mismo es algo que podría
ocurrir la Inteligencia artificial
tomando control sobre las actividades
humanas o no sé si han leído en 1984
desde George orwell que hablaba de esta
situación en la que el los derechos de
los de los seres humanos son
subordinados a los intereses de control
y vigilancia de los gobiernos también
ocurre el temor de que de que pueda que
los intereses comerciales
lleven la prioridad en este en este en
este futuro que me entusiasma que
estamos viendo que que información que
antes no podíamos acceder que no
podíamos integrar de manera rápida ahora
mismo sí lo podemos hacer y podemos
mejorar el consejo y la ayuda que le
damos a los pacientes doctores es
esperanzador también escuchar No las
partes positivas que pueden tener estas
herramientas yo lo quería hacer una
última pregunta sobre por ejemplo el uso
de aplicaciones que ya se están
generalizando mucho como chat chipitío
chat gpt que hay muchas personas que lo
vemos en redes sociales lo están usando
por ejemplo para tener planes de deporte
o planes nutricionales sin tener que
acudir a un especialista que qué opinión
le merece Esto se debe siempre usar
estas herramientas con supervisión
médica
es mejor es mejor aunque estas
herramientas están creciendo están
aprendiendo muy rápidamente y hemos
visto como
otras otras herramientas Pues
básicamente integran muchísima
información que nosotros no podemos
hacerlo pero ahora mismo el consejo y yo
creo que va a seguir siendo a futuro es
utilizar este esta tecnología con la
ayuda de un experto para poder tomar las
decisiones más adecuadas basadas en esa
experticia en la información Doctor
Muchas gracias por todos los consejos
que nos da hoy pero también queremos
agradecerle por tres años de consejos y
de información médica y de salud que nos
ha dado aquí en France 24 empezando como
una voz Pues por la tranquilidad no en
medio de una crisis como la pandemia de
covid 19 y después en la sección de
salud de corazón Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos todo este tiempo
de corazón Muchas gracias por la
oportunidad y ha sido un honor y un
privilegio por acompañarlos durante
estos tres años Gracias Oscar que hoy
nos acompaña Pues por última vez antes
pues bien Sí gracias también al doctor
le Quiero agradecer también al doctor
Oscar Franco porque fue una voz
fundamental en toda esta crisis del Kobe
19 para France 24 mar también gracias
por las noticias sobre la salud mañana
La espero con con nueva información
mañana volvemos con más Andrés